and here's here's why i don't think
sitting and waiting is going to work out
for you and hoping
that um when you open your gym it's
going to work out
good morning everyone happy monday i
hope you guys are had a good restful
weekend or maybe not hope you were not
resting at all just selling
tons of people into remote fitness over
the weekend and hopefully you were
but if you were not then this message is
for you so i'm calling this theo [ __ ]
moment i was having a conversation with
a friend of mine
um who's uh in the same space as us and
uh
he was talking to me about some of the
beliefs that he's getting over the phone
um with some of the gym owners that he's
talking to etc and um
it was kind of interesting because he
was saying that you know these things
change week to week
um but he said right now everyone's in
denial phase he said right now they're
in the phase of
i'm gonna i'm gonna hold out i think i
can wait a couple more weeks
for this to be over and i guess i'm here
to say that i don't think that's gonna
work out
for you um and here's here's why i don't
think
sitting and waiting is going to work out
for you and hoping that
when you open your gym it's going to
work out i'm calling this the oh [ __ ]
moment
because right now i think that there's
still a certain sense of hope
right i think that when they turn the
lights back on when they turn the
economy back on when they let gyms back
which by the way will be last
but when they let us go back to business
and open our doors
you're going to open your doors and i
think a lot a lot fewer people are going
to come back than you think
and i think that what's going to happen
is going to be a slower recovery than
most people anticipate because
people are still weary etc
and i think some people will just like
always
like there's a reason the on-demand
economy is the on-demand economy
right everyone thought that people i was
literally it's so funny i had an
internet troll yesterday or two days ago
who commented on an ad and literally
just saying stupid things
uh like stupid like trying to be smart
but saying stupid things
uh and he was like as soon as online
fitness as soon as the gyms open back up
all this online fitness stuff is going
to go away and i was like
really you think that people are just
going to choose a less convenient option
after they come back he's like well
people really value
the in-person you know blah blah blah
right
people said the exact same thing about
blockbuster
against netflix they're like the ceo is
a blockbuster because it's so easy to
rationalize
our like human beings don't want to
think of bad case scenarios and so we
rationalize that we don't need to change
right and so blockbuster executives when
they're like hey are you concerned about
this online streaming stuff they were
like no
people always value making a night
making an
evening going and picking up you know
picking out their movie
walking inside and getting their candy
like it's become an experience and so we
think that people will continue to value
this experience
guess what they were [ __ ] wrong
people would rather just click on the
cops and do nothing
right is the experience of being at your
couch
better than the experience of shopping
at blockbuster i would say no i
really miss blockbuster a lot of times
but i didn't miss enough to not use
netflix or use netflix way more
right and so the reality is that people
will always choose their convenience
and i think what happened very like
recently or currently right now
is that a huge piece of the marketplace
that never otherwise would have tried
online training
or maybe would have in the next decade
it took
all of the remote services and drop
dragged it 10 years into the future in
terms of mass adoption it was forced
adoption
all right and so i think a large
percentage of people are going to say
a larger than most gym owners anticipate
are going to stay in a remote setting
right i think a lot of people are still
like their jobs here's the others oh
[ __ ] moment is that people
some of the companies that did layoffs
may not rehire everyone right because
the demand is not going to be what it
was at the single greatest moment in
economic history
i mean like the best economy ever that
happened before this
and so just like the oh [ __ ] moment is
going to be when you turn the lights on
and people don't show up right which
transparently will be great for me
because i'm just going to market the
[ __ ] out of the gyms that want to work
with us because like
that will be when marketing is more
important than ever because you're going
to have to differentiate and get your
name out there more than anyone else is
right um but let's rewind the clock real
quick what do you need to do now
right what do you need to do now because
the airship moment will come now some
people have have stronger communities
than others right
and i always want to put my disclaimer
for good operators right if you're an
amazing operator and you haven't lost
anyone then you'll probably recover
better than people who have lost people
right because you have a stronger
community you have more bonding coaches
you have a better culture etc right
um but what should you do now
so it is my belief and just looking at
the math i'm going to do this big
presentation for gym lords don't worry
i did a huge statistical model looking
at uh the difference between
roi on remote versus roi in person
and the question is whether or not you
want to be a business owner or a gym
owner and that's a very real question
like super super real that's a personal
question right but if you're in this to
maximize making money because i've had
tons of gyms who flew out during our vip
days and said
alex i want to make a million dollars a
year and i said it's not going to happen
in one gym
right now talking heads of gurus will be
like you can totally like show me the
[ __ ] bank statement
all right and then i'll and then i'll
believe you right but no i like
it's not from one facility unless you
have a massive
massive facility and typically group
training personal training set will be
only
a part of that right like if you have 6
000 members paying 100
a month like lifetime then sure you can
make a million dollars a year right but
most people didn't invest five million
dollars into their build out right
so it's understanding relative scope
okay so
in my belief there is no way better than
right now
to for the best operators to be able to
build a million dollar
income business two three four million
dollar top line
business because one we're
we're marketing a 25 mile radius and
seeing zero decrease
in sales percentages all right it's
number one number two
our remote gyms right now are closing a
higher percentage of leads than they did
in person
that's a function of one major thing is
that they're getting 40 percent of their
leads
onto it into a sales conversation
compared to
20 you know whatever they were doing
before all right so they have twice as
many at bats
and so even if they're not as good on
the phone they're not twice as bad over
the phone
right and so they're a little if you
look at right now the average closing
percentage of 29
so they're closing 29 over the phone
they were closing 42
in person all right but if you get twice
as many at bats you actually still net
more sales
and so number one you can have a bigger
geographic radius so the many
people that i've talked to says like i
want to have a bigger impact here's how
you have a bigger impact you can go
remote and help people are not in your
neighborhood
number two lead costs are cheaper not
because of
the ads the ad impressions and stuff
because that's temporary right
we've already seen it go back to normal
so the at the cost per impression is has
gone 100 back to
normal since two or three weeks ago all
right people are advertising again
um but it's because when you draw from
bigger radius you get cheaper leads
that's just period if you run a an ad
nationally it's just as like challenge
or whatever you'll get you know 25 cent
leads
the issue is how do you create trust how
do you create a sale or trustworthy
environment for a lead
to opt in and then buy something on the
first phone call right and that's where
having
i would consider like the semi-local
appeal
automatically gives you gives you one or
two trust points in your direction which
is allowing us
to make sales on these first calls but
if we're looking at it purely from a
math perspective which i would urge you
to be a business owner not a gym owner
for the moment
right now our guys are essentially
breaking even
on the first transaction right now
they're used to
making two to one three to one four to
one et cetera on their first transaction
right
but you are limited by your
your capacity to fulfill in terms of how
many people you can have at each time
uh you're limited by your lead flow
because let's be real like lead flow of
a 25 mile radius
is always going to be higher and cheaper
than in a five ball radius because it's
quadratic right so if you have a five
mile radius
and then you'd go from five to ten you
didn't double the amount of people that
you
saw you pied it right so 3.14 or
whatever the math is but it's basically
let me put in layman's terms if you have
a 12-inch pizza and you have a 24-inch
pizza a 24-inch pizza is not twice as
big as a 12-inch pizza you can fit like
four 12-inch pieces inside of a 24-inch
pizza because that's how
circles work with with with it's called
quadratic expansion but anyways
um and so when you go to a 25-mile
radius you're talking 10 times
you know i mean the amount of people
that you would be reaching otherwise or
20 or 50 or whatever
the math is and so because of that you
can have a much bigger reach
help more people cons like anybody who's
ever struggled with lead flow
that doesn't have to happen anymore like
you don't have to struggle with lead
flow anymore because it's literally
enormous and you pretty much can always
get lead flow
if your target is big enough all right
and so putting all these things together
cheaper leads bigger geographic radius
consistent lead generation
a consistent 11 of leads close which is
what we're seeing right now which is
higher than most people do in person
breaking even on the front end and
having 80 uh gross margin on the back
end
like you're talking about spending you
know right now
if you spend 1500 you'll make six
thousand dollars in front end revenue in
30 days
that's what the math is right that's the
average all right that's the average
okay fifteen hundred dollars that's 6600
is the actual number
uh of upfront cash in the first 30 days
for an online business
you know many people have tried to start
an online business too many online
business gurus there are
and the reason they don't have an agency
set up or whatever
is because they can't guarantee an
outcome right they only tow
the one or two testimonials that they
have of the hundreds of students they
have
all right i'm giving you the average
numbers average
average for online so if you wanted to
make a six-figure income
all right it would take you 30 days to
build a recurring revenue stream
if you spent uh uh if you spent fifteen
hundred dollars
it would take if you spent fifteen
hundred dollars you close thirty uh
thirty nine percent
so let's just bump it to make it
conservative so if you spent twenty two
hundred dollars in ad spend over the
first thirty days
you would be able to have fifty people
in your online remote uh business
after you lost 44 for not going into
continuity
all right so i'm accounting for that
that you only convert 60
into continuity at 200 bucks a month
right that's a 10 000
a month business remote and you can do
it in 30 days
like averages if you're average you can
do it in 30 days
right now and so the big question that
you have to ask is
one am i holding out for what's going to
happen
that i don't know about because you
don't know what's gonna happen i don't
either that's just my guess
but like you don't know what's gonna
happen but what i can tell you is the
opportunity is there
and so in the next 30 days in the next
60 days if you wanted to
build yourself a six figure or multi-six
figure online income you
could do it i know that a lot of my gym
lords won't do that they're gonna go
back to the gyms and that's fine
i'm here to serve i'm here to provide
whatever value the community that i have
asked for
but if i were an enterprising
[ __ ] which i am i would be
strongly considering this
it has been very difficult for me to not
throw my hat back in the ring
and start sonic fitness at large because
when i see those types of numbers
in terms of acquisition i was like hmm
how many sales guys we got i was like i
wonder if i i was like i wonder if
there's a bunch of gym owners who went
out of business so i could just hire to
become salespeople
because when i see that kind of stuff
three to one four to one up front
you know what i mean ten to one at 30
days ten to one at 60 days
60 days like in gym launch i lose money
the first 30 to 60 days
right and like i'm just i just know the
math game right i'm just willing to make
decisions with math
if you are able to make decisions with
math right now and not let your emotions
and not let your fear
and not let your discomfort around
learning a new skill which is selling
over the phone because it's the only
thing you have to do
that's it as long as you acquire that
skill set which by the way
will set you up better for when you get
back to the gym because if you can sell
over the phone you convert a high
percentage of leads always
right if you can just learn that skill
you can have an online business
simple as that right now and i hope and
i and i think
my hunch is that that buying behavior
will not change
people will be now the mass market has
been introduced to what online training
is like most people even know what it
was
now they know what it is all right and
so that that like you're underestimating
how big of a deal it is for them to even
recognize
that industry all right and so one
people will now know
what online training is number two they
will be comfortable more comfortable
buying in a remote setting here
appreciate over the phone
yeah this is after the lights get turned
back on because you're like well i don't
want to change things you know
temporarily because something you know
when what happens when you go later
what if you have a business that just
cash flows later and then you have your
gym because
many people like i won't even get into
it but over the phone you just say
yeah you know when covet happened we
started doing our first consults over
the phone and it ended up just being
more convenient for people so we just
stuck with it
anyways so what's your name why'd you
click on the ad right like you can just
preface the
the sale and then everything else flows
like normal right
because this has given us the biggest
reason of all time the biggest
why am i remote why are you doing this
over the phone why are we doing this
online
it has now given everyone permission to
have that reason
that we never had before right and
educated like thank you to the
government for educating
all consumers on online and remote
setting fitness
right thank you to the news thank you to
everybody for helping us out
all right so i say this to say uh
i think that for everyone who's holding
out and waiting i don't think that's a
smart decision
um i don't want to be right but i think
i probably will be
um i think a lot of people are turning
their lights back on and a lot of people
aren't gonna come back
right uh think of this like a vacation
it's like all these people are like you
know what
actually i'm i'm going to keep doing
things at home or you know it's actually
kind of more convenient for me to just
kind of do it on my own schedule
instead of having to go there come back
shower all that stuff it was just kind
of easier for me
because convenience and speed always win
with humans
always you have to always bet on
convenience because we are lazy
right and especially when it comes to
fitness all right
and so it's like well that's why and
that's why many people can't market
outside of five mile radius because
people are too lazy to drive further
right they're too lazy you're like but
our gym's so great it's like yeah but
they're gonna choose a shittier gym
that's closer to them
just being real right and so if you can
take the service to them which we now
have the opportunity to learn the skill
set to do that
you can by the time this thing turns
back on probably have more recurring
profit
profit income than you did before this
um but it's for the people who want to
win
and who want to take action otherwise if
you're just going to wait totally cool
we'll help you when we want to come back
because we we do that too
but uh that's just my that's my two
cents right now and i know that whenever
i talk about online it's always
polarizing
but i have a really hard time not
speaking my mind about something that i
think is more profitable
and i think it's lower risk and i think
in the post corona economy
um the businesses that will win are the
ones that have lower overhead
and have higher margins and have a
higher ability to reach customers where
they're at
and all of those boxes get checked and
then you get all the added bonus
benefits benefits that i said earlier
virtually unlimited lead flow
cheaper leads bigger radius higher
profit margin you get all of those
things on top of everything i said so
anyways don't let the other ship moment
happen to you
take action now start selling remote i
think
it is it is incredibly incredibly
awesome right now um and you should get
in all right
keeping great catch you soon all right
have a great day and uh
drop a chat a chat or a light but not a
chat drop a comment or like or
you know review or something like that
if you liked if you didn't then i'm
sorry
all right get you soon bye
you